We have all heard the hype about three-dimensional - some call it the Third Industrial Revolution or the three-dimensional industrial revolution.
But what exactly is 3D printing? How much impact will it have in the future?
The concept is very simple: just as your printer prints ink on the paper, the 3D printers blow out
The materials - whether plastic, metal or cement - are three dimensional.
But instead of printing one layer of ink as you would a regular printer, stack up several
Layers overlapping each other to form complex 3D structures. Think of it as a process
Chop bread, but in reverse! After placing the first layer, the others are placed above it
And so on, until the whole loaf of bread is completely re-installed! Translation of AraSense _
Have you lost or broken something and you can not buy it anymore? Simply create the design or carry it
From the Internet, and print it in 3D! Do you have a specific idea about a special gift or a personal holiday
Did not find it? Print it! In fact, GE's Templer 3Dprintmygift.tumblr.com does that precisely in the holiday season
We'll link to the description below. If you need moving parts in your design,
, Simply leave the printer gaps in the selected areas, or use a gel
Decomposable or washable later.
In terms of design, 3D printing paves the way for incredible, manufactured products
Customized to suit your needs. This is not limited to furniture, shoes and appliances
Which are designed to fit your lifestyle, but things like artificial limbs can be designed entirely and customarily
For the user, reverse general products with standardized measurement.
Do you need something small and complex? Ideal 3D printers create layers
Up to about 100 micrometers, and some advanced printers can print something as small as 16 micrometers.
To understand this from another perspective, the width of the typical bacterial cell ranges from 1-10 micrometers.
These doors have been opened to use particles as ink, and this has led to printing
3-D drugs successfully, such as ibuprofen. Small atoms are well organized
To obtain the desired drug effect.
are you hungry? In the future, you may be able to order a "Seri" print a three-dimensional meal
Match your wish.
But perhaps the most important application is the creation of three-dimensional structures of living cells
Or bio-ink. Instead of using plastic or metal, imagine a three-dimensional texture printed to replace
Damaged skin, or to reproduce complete organs. Instead of needing a donor for a member,
You only print it depending on your genes. Surprisingly, this technique is already being developed.
With regard to burns and abrasions, a scanner is used on the patient's wound, forming a personal leather map.
After that, the printer places the cells one layer at a time, even
Cover the area.
Members are more complex because of their large size, their vascular networks, and their interactions with the body.
A scanner takes x-ray images of a patient's kidney, for example in the form of transverse sections
With incredibly complex details. Like any other, these members are reproduced
Layer layer, tailored to each individual. Although this needs many years
To become practical, but it will inevitably have a significant impact in the medical community.
So, although you'll need a while before you get a 3D printer in your home, be confident
That when you get it, the world will be a different place.
But if you can not wait too long, GE will give you three-dimensional printing on its vacation
On the third of December - the third of December for the "trilogy" of dimensions! To celebrate. They will print personalized 3D gifts
To their fans throughout the day. All you have to do is 3dprintmygift.tumblr.com and so to choose
Twitter and Twitter form to get the chance to have it printed and shipped to your home in times of holidays!
Check it out!
Subscribe to more weekly science videos!